[Music]
we find a lot of joy in cute things
whether that's baby animal videos or you
know cartoons and the reason that we
find this joy is actually stems from
deep in our evolution
so cuteness is actually a set of
aesthetic features that are designed to
unlock playful and nurturing behavior in
us and for children even as young as six
years old cute features actually prompt
these kinds of nurturing behaviors so
cuteness is actually a kind of defense
mechanism that helps you know protect
vulnerable young individuals from harm
as they grow older so cute features
consists of a few basic things usually
round features so big round eyes a round
head that's usually a little bit too big
for its body and these aesthetic signals
actually prompt playful and nurturing
impulses in a caregiver and so the idea
is that when something has these cute
features whether that's a baby or a baby
animal or even a cartoon these features
prompt us to feel a sense of play and
they actually prompt us to engage more
deeply with that cute thing so that that
thing that cute animal gets a lot of
stimulation that it means for its brain
to develop this one's a little kooky but
research in Japan has shown that looking
at cute things actually can increase
concentration one of the reasons that
they speculate that cuteness might
influence concentration is that cute
things are associated with nurturing and
nurturing is very focused and
detail-oriented activity and so when
people perform tasks after looking at
pictures of baby animals they actually
found that they were more attentive to
detail and more conscientious in the
tasks that they did so this might be
another way to both improve performance
but also bring a little bit of joy to
the work space I do this in my own work
space by adding googly eyes to things
which is a very
only way to do it but it actually brings
a lot of joy and maybe it also helps me
catch errors in my writing
[Music]